TikTok has become a place where so many women
and single mothers are able to come together,
talk about how fucked up the family court is,
talk about their personal experiences,
spread the fucking truth
about what it was like to really be a trad wife.
You're not gonna erase us.
We're the millennials.
We're not gonna just fucking go away.
We're the fucking MySpace generation.
You think some social media is gonna come out,
and I don't think it's for me,
bitch, I'm one of the ones that started social media.
We were the ones that were adding music to our pages
and learning HTML and shit to fuck with it.
We're the generation that is running
the tech industry right now.
We're the generation.
That's why there's no more plumbers and electricians,
because we're the motherfuckers online.
If a fucking social media platform comes out, of course
I feel like I have a place there to have my voice heard.
And so among all the other reasons that it feels like
they're trying to take TikTok away from us,
I definitely feel like it is just one more assault
against women.
It's one small
little tunnel that we have found
to communicate with each other,
find each other,
try to yell to the other women
to see if they can hear us.
You know, create these pathways to escape
and create these pathways to income.
Because this is not an MLM,
the TikTok shop.
This is truly just Cutting out the middle man.
Jeff Bezos no longer gets a cut.
The moms get to work directly with the manufacturers
in Fucking China.
And they're like, hey,
can you sell my lamp?
And I'll give you,
you know, 10 cents for everyone you sell.
And we're like, got you.
And we tell all our friends about it,
and some friends wanna buy it,
some strangers wanna buy it.
And that's how so many moms are making it.
So many people,
young dudes.
I see fucking young dudes that are out here.
How you think they're ballers?
They're making money on TikTok?
Like, it's complete bullshit that the band got passed
and that it's. It's.
It's working its way through.
So I think we all need to be, like,
as loud as possible
in every way possible right now.